Andrew Tate is what men with no
self-esteem think High self-esteem looks
like unpack that a little bit so it's
funny like watching the rise of Tate
because he's like a copy and paste of
20 million plus copies sold the champion
the no [__] Champion official title I
think Mark Manson welcome welcome thank
you when subtle art came out and it blew
up and it was like at the top all the
best seller lists and stuff like
everybody in the publishing industry
were like oh you're like the new Phenom
debuted author overnight success I'm
like overnight success I've been
grinding on a Blog for 10 years like
what do you mean overnight success were
you good at the beginning or did you
stop oh dude that was a [__] disaster
I was a total disaster
you obviously became a great writer but
I want to talk about what you're doing
now which is the YouTube video or the
YouTube channel and it's not like the
main thing when I saw Mr Beast a light
bulb went off I was like I love Mr Beast
and like I've been watching his [__] for
a long time but one of my frustrations
with him is that it's all very
[Music]
intro to the camera here we got
three-time New York Times bestseller I
believe yeah we have uh 20 million plus
copies sold the champion the no [__]
Champion official title I think uh Mark
Manson welcome welcome thank you good to
be here uh been a fan for a while
um although I gotta admit I read like a
ton of your blogs and I didn't read the
book until
like I said I've actually finished the
book but until we booked this interview
I was like I should probably go and read
the actual book that he's most famous
for yeah but there's something to like
the fun of like oh I liked his his old
[__] you know like the cool band thing I
was a fan before he was cool yeah that
that whole thing yeah
so when I was writing that intro I was
like this is pretty great pretty
impressive yeah but I always wonder this
like when you were younger like let's
say let's say a researcher was watching
you when you were like I don't know
between the ages of 10 and 20. would it
have been noticeable
that you approached things a little
different even when you were younger I
was definitely different when I was
young for sure I don't think it would
have been obvious that I would I would I
was gonna end up an author or
in the personal development industry or
whatever but uh you know my whole life
my teachers were like
Mark's different he's special we wish he
would do his homework uh we wish he
would stay awake in class
but he could do great things one day
like that was kind of the constant
refrain throughout my childhood because
you just weren't interested in school or
what was the situation yeah I was bored
and and
I would I would just whatever I was into
that's just kind of what I like I used
to bring poker books to class and read
them in the middle like physics class
and my teachers would get mad at me I'm
like well I'm just like studying poker
you know were you big into like yeah
during like the Chris Moneymaker phase
basically yeah
that's cool
um did you ever like go all in on it I
tried so it's funny
um
early on in college I I decided to sit
down and take it really seriously I made
a few thousand bucks which when you're
like 19 or 20. it's massive right I'm
like oh my God I can pay rent all summer
my poker winnings and then uh you were
in college yeah so you're paying like
you know 20 grand for school but
ignoring school to make 300 in a sit and
go exactly like I've stayed up till 5
a.m like I made 200 bucks last night
right
um and and then I hit my first big
downswing and lost like half my bankroll
in like maybe three days four days right
and I was like oh [__] I don't think I
can pay rent this month you know I'm
like this kind of sucks actually yeah
it's like a very very unhealthy uh
unhealthy life I love the game but the
lifestyle that it requires like the
grinding the the patience like the the
emotional fortitude to like handle the
ups and downs it's
yeah after about six months I was like I
don't think I'm built for this right and
you there's a lot of like degenerates
you end up hanging around around like
okay uh doing it so you kind of look
around you're like this isn't healthy
it's like yeah yeah it's like they're
not smoking but there's like a
secondhand smoke of their like life
that's like I don't want to be inhaling
right now for sure for sure so I think
we had kind of a similar
um set of Interest maybe it's like very
common for I don't know guys that are
going through some Rites of Passage it's
like yeah you think you can play poker
or like count cards in blackjack I mean
yeah yeah and then you sort of move on
to like the next phase yeah exactly
um where you know there's a I think
2005. a book comes out that I know
influenced you it influenced me yep uh
do you know what I'm talking about
where's the game the game Neil Strauss
yep ironically my girlfriend my
girlfriend in high school before I went
to college we were like yeah let's break
up we're going to college and yeah two
different places we were pretty mature
about it but she was like here's a book
and I was like that's the best
backhanded compliment gift I've ever
received it's like your girlfriend
giving you a book called The Game and
it's like you need this for college yeah
yeah
um describe how did you find it and what
was like the next 24 hours after you
started reading it you know it's funny
it it hit me at depending on your
perspective the exact best or worst
moment possible
um
so my first girlfriend in high school
had just cheated on me and left me for
another dude and I was completely
heartbroken just
gutted
you know weepy whiny and sucks even more
in high school because like leaving you
is like she's still there yeah right
yeah yeah we're still in the hallway
yeah well I Would by this time I was in
college okay but like we had gotten
together in high school anyway it was we
didn't we didn't you made the right move
so we didn't split up we were like oh
we're in love we're gonna make it work
I'm gonna drive back every other week
and all this [__] and it's like no
that's a horrible idea and so of course
she found another guy you should
actually look in the camera be like to
the person do that 18 right now don't do
that it's not gonna work the long
distance girlfriend when you both go to
college you just don't do it and uh so
anyway I I was absolutely heartbroken
and distraught and just had like very
angry and confused and I remember being
in a bookstore and seeing seeing that
book like on the table
and I remember my first reaction was
discussed I was like it's like what is
this like who would read this right and
then I'm like yeah yeah maybe I'll read
a few pages and and I mean Neil's such a
good writer like it talk about somebody
who knows how to like hook your
attention and kind of suck you into a
world
um
yeah I just I think I sat down and read
probably the
first 50 hundred Pages there in the
bookstore uh and then I think I read the
entire thing in just a couple days and
and that was pretty much it like I was
like all right like
you know the one girl who ever liked me
completely [__] me over broke my heart
and every other girl I've ever met seems
to have no interest so clearly I'm not
doing something right you know like I'm
willing to give anything a go at this
point and uh so yeah I I kind of got
sucked into that world for
um well
I guess four years five years uh and
then it eventually kind of stumbled into
my first business was in that world as
well yeah and I want to talk about that
because I think it's again like I it was
like a formative phase of my life too
and so today I think a bunch of people
rightfully so you know like like you
admire you follow you and you like add a
lot of value to people's lives right
like
even though self-help kind of like
sometimes gets a bad rap like you're
almost by definition helping people with
yourself frankly the most important
thing
but I would say like
it's probably a rabbit hole you went
down now and content you create now but
that previous Rabbit Hole you went down
and content you created was around
uh there it is there it is uh oh yeah
this is your first book right yep uh
models attract women through honesty yep
um at least that subtitle is like you
know well we can get to this in a second
but before that that was a very very
intentional
yeah that that's jumping ahead a couple
years but yeah so let's start with okay
so you read the game you get you know
kind of the uh I always say this about
Tim ferriss's book the four hour work
week is like after you read that book
you have the four hour fever yep so for
the next four hours you reconsider your
entire life and like a fever dream yeah
and I just tell people that when I give
them the book I'm like you're gonna have
let's schedule some time you're gonna
need this weekend to have the four hour
fever
um same kind of thing happens with the
game and you become you start I guess
you describe it you start practicing it
so let's start start with like you start
actually practicing it for people who
haven't read the game
and don't know the core principles of it
like what stood out to you at that time
of like oh I used to do things this way
but this is like this kind of thing I'm
learning this new skill I'm learning
well so the there's a funny thing about
the game which is and it's it's funny
too because I would put the four hour
work week in this category as well and
that those are if I was to make a list
of like the five most impactful books
that I've ever read in my life those two
would be on the list for sure right that
said
I don't actually like the majority of
advice in both of those books I don't
think actually was applicable to me or
actually worked for me right it was more
just showing what was possible right so
um
and definitely more so in in the game's
case than for you know for our work week
it it it's primarily principles and
mindsets you know my my issue with the
four hour work week was that it just it
made it sound way easier than it was
it's it's you know the the real four
hour work week is uh you know work 16
hours a day so you can make money while
you sleep
um but with the game I think the the
really powerful concept that was very
life-changing was that social skills and
dating are skills that you can practice
and get better at right like that never
occurred to me it just occur like
up to that point in my uh my life
like most young people I just kind of
assumed like well
either girls are into you or they're not
right and if they're not you're kind of
you're kind of [__] right right or not
[__] in that case but like it so
reading that book and being like oh you
can actually go out and practice and get
better social skills and get better at
being sexual and flirting and and
connecting with women and doing all
these things like that those are all
skills that you can practice like that
was very revelatory for me that said
when I actually went out and tried to do
the stuff in the game which was a bunch
of cheesy pickup lines and they call
them routines like we're like stories
magic routines stories you would
memorize and all this stuff it was a
[__] disaster like it was just it was
completely corny and and I felt very
inauthentic and out of place but like
what was impactful is that it got me out
of the house and like talking to women
on a regular basis and I realized like
hey if I actually just get myself in
front of a bunch of cute girls
I'm actually I'm not that bad like I can
talk I can make a joke
like I can use my own personality as a
starting point and just build from there
right and so that's kind of what I
started doing through throughout College
and by the end of college I kind of had
developed a reputation as
the big party guy the player you know
the guy who had four different
girlfriends or whatever for me I had the
same experience you had except for uh
the lamest Moment The Rock Bottom moment
is when you hear another guy saying the
same thing because he read the same book
and you're like oh [__] there's like 100
of us running around yeah it's like this
thing I was gonna say by itself was
actually a little bit cringe yeah
maximally cringe if she heard this from
another guy and I was like oh okay I
can't just like it there's no memorizing
your way to success here but the
principles I thought were good and
you're right the forcing function of
like getting you to like kind of uh
believe the self-confidence to believe
that this might actually work that you
can actually approach somebody and have
a good conversation and that that could
lead to something yeah it was like
pretty powerful yeah I even do this with
podcasts like I have
like a note of like what's the first
thing I want to talk about with you like
I kind of know that the next 90 minutes
will be great either way sure but that
first minute is like the social anxiety
piece which is like the same thing with
with these pickup artists which was like
most people just aren't even approaching
anyone yeah with anything that's a
interest that might lead to a
conversation
um so for me that was like the bigger
thing do you uh still have that kind of
like
do you think about that moment of social
anxiety that first
um that first moment in like was the
game helpful in like getting those Reps
for sure I mean I I had a lot of social
anxiety when I was young and and it's
funny because it took me a long time to
appreciate that that you know because
when you're kind of naive and a newbie
you look at all the pickup lines and you
think it's the pickup line that's
working right and it's like no it's
actually the pickup line is just the
excuse to kind of get you through your
anxiety to give give you the courage to
actually go say something it doesn't
really matter what you're saying right
and uh I actually had a very Ford you
know kind of like you hearing over here
and another guy say a word I actually
got very lucky early on because I was
trying to use some of the stuff I read
in the game I started I tried to do like
some [__] coin magic tricks and stuff
like just total disaster and uh I
remember I I I was having no luck
whatsoever and
I actually got very fortunate in that I
was in a bar or something I was talking
to these three girls and I was like
trying to do a magic trick and they were
like really into it and really excited
and I kept [__] it up
and then like it kind of got awkward and
at a certain point they realized they're
like wait like you're just doing a thing
like kind of hit on us and I'd like
tried to make a joke and it was super
lame or something and they kind of
rolled their eyes and they started to
walk away and I was like wait I have
another magic trick and I remember one
of the girls turned around and she
looked at me and she was like you know
you were kind of cute like you should
just
be yourself
I was like
you know like had to explode and almost
and and that was kind of one of those
first moments where I'm like you know
what like why don't I just start
like use my personality as the Baseline
and then iterate on stuff that already
feels natural and trying to instead of
trying to be like some [__] weird
dude in a book right you know that I
can't believe I spent ten thousand
dollars in two years of my life studying
all this [__] I could have just like
walked up and been like hi where are you
from right and it would have gotten me
the exact same results there's a book
that's like uh food diet book I haven't
even read the book but the last page of
the book is like a summary uh you might
know the book because you're you're an
author
um it's like here's the like after all
the studies and all the diets because
like you know there's like a trillion
diets out there and like they're like
some are super super complicated you're
like you know peeing on a strip to see
if you're like in ketosis or not yeah
yeah you can do you can take it to the
nth degree and it was like yeah so it
seems like the rules are
um you know eat real food like not like
package processors like eat real food
not too much yeah and like and it was
like that was like basically the the
core of the advice yeah and it's like
oh
yeah and like but if you actually
intensely followed that you get all the
results you want but like there's this
thing where we sort of search for this
like other answer the secret answer yes
it can't possibly be just that there
there's a weird thing that happens in a
lot of these industries which is
the concepts and frame Frameworks that
sell well are often counterproductive
right and you see this in diet nutrition
you see this in exercise for sure you
see this in social skills personal
development self-help you see it in the
pickup world like it's really sexy like
when a guy stands up and he says I have
a three-step model that works every time
and you're gonna get laid like tile and
you're gonna lose 100 pounds and you
know
it's really sexy and you really want to
buy it and you like want to believe it
and it works and it makes people
millions of dollars but then it doesn't
actually it's not actually good advice
right whereas the good advice like this
is the other hard thing about these
industries is that the good advice is
boring and so and the things that work
and again this is true in personal
development it's true social skill is
true with diet nutrition everything the
stuff that works is boring it's
it's not the information that's hard
it's simply doing it it's implementing
right consistently over a long period of
time that's the hard part and there's no
easy way to sell a solution to that so
the easy thing to sell a solution for is
you know my three steps at work every
time and I see this everywhere like
because I'm mostly in the kind of
startup business World
um and like you know Warren Buffett uh
they're like you know Warren you're
pretty open about your strategies yeah
um and they're not like that complicated
um why do you think that more people
don't do this and it was either Hammer
Charlie Munger that were like because
nobody wants to get rich slow yep it's
like yeah we just did this in public and
he's like you know I made most of my
wealth like from the ages of 70 to 90.
and like uh you know nobody wants to do
that nobody wants to hear that yeah they
want to hear that guy who's not done
this yeah tell them that they can do XYZ
faster or in a different way in a
complicated way that yeah you know you
just didn't have the info now that you
got the info now it's all gonna work
yeah all right same thing like uh you
know Y combinator which is the most
successful like you know startup uh
investor and and uh accelerator their
number one advice is just make something
people want and they're like What's the
great startup advice like well but the
the way it helps is like if you just
tell someone that they don't know how to
use it yeah but the quest like the audit
when you're like so do you think that
people want this they're like of course
it was like cool so what tells you that
what what evidence is showing you that
people want this and they're like well
we don't have any dude it's it's like
that bell curve meme where it's like you
know genius
like just make something people want and
then in the middle of the bell curve
it's like well you've got to have these
12 steps and figure out these strategy
you know and then the Jedi is like just
make something people want I love that
man that's right
across so many domains it's amazing yeah
and I catch myself all the time and I'm
like I need what would the Jedi oh the
Jedi would just say like yeah do it
because it's fun instead of like yeah
you know all these other things yeah
um when you look back because Ben's been
flashing a bunch of your like I know
it's been been oh God he flashes a bunch
of your things that are like this is the
cringe section of that don't worry it
gets better the interview will get
better but this is the Korean section uh
but you have like a bunch of these
things that I'm like they're like just
amazing headlines we're gonna talk
titles later because you're like a title
Master sure but when you look back
do you how what's the meaning you put or
like what's the label you put on these
things I think we're both of the mindset
that like life is not really about what
happens it's kind of like what you what
you make of it and also what you tell
yourself the story you tell yourself
about what happened yeah um so like when
you look back on that phase
is it just like
um
cringe and I don't want to ever think
about like I hope my I forget about that
is it like no that was actually really
useful for me in these ways is it just
funny now like what's your reaction now
it's a really good question I I would
say it's probably like one-third cringe
one-third I think it was actually really
important informative in a lot of ways
and then one third just kind of funny
and just like can you believe that
happened uh actually when I moved out
here to La
um I met up with Neil for the first time
and we spent a day together and we spent
like half the day just kind of being
like can you believe that happened right
you believe we actually did that I I
look back though especially now that a
little bit more time has gone by
I really do think that there was kind of
an underrated factor and I think this is
very relevant because this is starting
to happen again with Gen Z
with
I think the pickup artist industry is
underrated as a cultural or social
phenomenon particularly for young men
trying to find Identity or find
themselves in like a very confusing
world with a lot of information uh
because it's when I look back at that
time like yeah
like we
in the industry Co our the coaches we
used to joke with each other it was like
yeah we all came for the women but we
stayed for the for the other dudes yeah
like it's it's most of the guys who
really got into that it wasn't about the
girls it was they needed to feel
accepted and and and validated by other
men and and just I guess I don't know
their masculinity right there's like a
very there was like this yearning for
like a masculine role model and
I always found that I was very aware of
that at the time but I didn't really
know what to make of it uh but as the
years have gone on I look back and I
think like I think it blew up to the
extent it did because because of that I
don't think it was really about the
dating or the girls I think it was just
it was a generation of kind of
post-feminism
a generation of like men who had
fewer father figures fewer Role Models a
lot more confusion about like who
they're supposed to be in the world and
I think we're that's that cycle is
coming back today and you're seeing a
lot of that happen again with a
different set of role models and uh a
different industry well let's talk about
one of them uh so I think Andrew Tate is
like the for sure uh you know poster boy
right now that uh thank you pull up that
tweet he has you have a great tweet
about energy I want to ask you yeah yeah
Andrew Tate is what men with no
self-esteem think High self-esteem looks
like as a rule narcissism is is always
mistaken for confidence by those who
have no confidence from there it doesn't
take much for the dynamic to turn
abusive slash exploitive yeah so it's
funny like watching Tate the rise of
Tate because
he just he's like a copy and paste of
half the guys that were in that industry
right you know it's like all the [__] he
says I'm like oh yeah I remember you
know this guy used to say that oh yeah
that guy used to say that too oh yeah
that guy made a lot of money saying that
you know like it's all the same [__]
just recycled in a new package I do
think Tate is uniquely charismatic and I
think he is an interesting backstory
that a lot of young men respect right
and so that that is it's given him a lot
more amplification it's also just a
different era with social media and
everything uh but
and he like layered on an MLM yeah yeah
right so he just combined like three of
the most powerful forces in the world
seriously pretty insane Charisma with
like this like cocktail of like words
that cast a spell on young men yeah and
then an MLM distribution model where
he's like look cut up clips of me and
post them everywhere and like that's how
you rise in the ranks and you get like
you're gonna make money by promoting me
it's which is insane it's honestly
somebody really needs to do uh I mean it
probably we probably need some time but
like 10 years from now I want to see
somebody do like a really good book
about him right and like a a fair book
not like
trying to smear like take an honest look
of like who was this guy why did he blow
up why did this work right like because
it's I think it's easy obviously you can
take the worst things that he said it's
no secret some of the bad things he said
and you can just hammer on those all day
but like I think that's way less
interesting than just trying to
understand like
why is there such a demand for this guy
again right like
I thought we kind of got over this and
this kind of ties back into my first
book models so like
the pickup industry by like 2009 2010
I'd really really become burnt out on on
just the toxicity of it and I I really
felt that there were kind of two strains
of dating relationship advice for men
one was
basically promoting narcissism
selfishness power dynamics right and
sure that stuff can get you laid a lot
but it's
it's at the expense of preventing any
sort of happy or joyous long-term
relationship or intimacy with any female
ever right so you're like giving up that
potential to just like put notches on
your bed post and brag to your buddies
and that is a very bad trade-off like if
if you look at just in the terms of a
man's overall lifespan that's a very bad
trade-off
um
and then so I was I was kind of like
okay how do we like detoxify this this
advice what does that look like
um how do we and it's not just about
treating women with respect but it's
treating yourself with respect too
because like what a lot of guys don't
realize is that
yeah obviously if you objectify women
it's bad for the women but it's bad for
you too because you're objectifying
yourself you're start you're basically
just measuring Yourself by how wet your
dick gets and like that's a very
demeaning way to view yourself and view
your own self-esteem and so I was kind
of fed up with the whole thing I knew I
wanted to get out I wanted to Pivot out
of the industry
and I was like well if I'm getting out
of the industry I might as well just
write the book that everybody needs to
hear and nobody wants to hear which is
that this is all toxic and [__] up and
stop doing it pretty good at the
beginning or did you suck oh dude I was
a [__] disaster
I was a total disaster
um
you do you want me to talk about the
content side or the marketing side uh
whatever's more interesting you you tell
me well I'll I'll start with the content
side it's less interesting but I'll
start with it because it's quicker which
is just like
most my content was bad at first and I
think that's true of anybody and you
just get those reps in you know I I you
back in the day back when blogs were
still a thing I used to get asked all
the time like how do I start a blog how
do I grow a Blog make make a living as a
blogger my answer was always the same
which is like write 100 blog posts come
ask me again right and uh have you seen
by the way Mr Beast has like almost the
exact verbatim answer yes and I love it
because yeah it's the exact same thing I
used to tell people and it's a
combination of like it's actually the
right advice because you need a bunch of
reps and you need to suck for a little
bit and get better just try to make each
of the next video better and nobody's
also it's a filter it's like are you
serious or are you not serious yes I
will help you if you're serious yes but
99 of you are not serious this is the
easy task exactly exactly and the funny
thing is too is that it's like most
people if they go write a hundred blog
posts and try to make each one better
by the 100th one they don't need the
advice anymore they know what they're
doing wrong they know what they need to
get better at so was there anything that
got you better what did you read
something or follow some or you know
model your stuff after someone like do
you remember how you got good in terms
of writing and content my two big
inspiration I was a huge Bill Simmons
fan back in the day wow we were like
very very alive
yeah back in the day page you know page
two yep and um it's I remember reading
his call I was like his column each week
was like an event in my life it was like
I was so excited to go read it and I
remember thinking I was like I want my
art because back then the meta in this
is pre-news feed pre-social media
everything so like in the blogosphere
the idea everything all traffic was
either SEO or
um the blog roll type thing yeah like
link farming like you know you would
like write something spicy so that a
bunch of other bloggers would want to
comment on it so they'd link to you and
like all this stuff and it'd be it was
very much a volume game so like the the
standard advice was always
you know don't write one big blog post a
day write 20 20 single paragraphs and
post those as individual blog posts each
day just that's what's going to make you
grow and I always hated that that always
felt very shitty and
uninspiring and so and I loved Bill
Simmons and I was like man I want to be
the Bill Simmons of my industry right
right like I want to have these like
Epic
10-page posts that that guys just get
lost in and like you know they like
schedule their week around right and you
end up feeling like a friend it's like
it's a hang yeah and I think it that
probably hurt me in the short run and it
helped me in the long run see it I tried
to meet up with him when uh so we came
out here I was like I want to schedule
yeah who's my dream guest I was like I
would love to have Bill Simmons on this
because I don't he doesn't do a lot of
like where he's the guest I don't I've
never really seen any to be honest yeah
he's like uh he's a big deal at Spotify
now so yeah he's you know he's yeah
that's fine but like whatever
who cares
he's written so if you ever if people
ever read this go read uh I think it's
called the consequences of caring
unbelievable post so good uh anyway
sorry continue so Bill Simmons inspired
you to be like I don't need to like sell
out to the algorithm the algorithm of
that time the meta of that time yeah and
it's I also think it helped that I I was
in a pretty niche in uh insulated
industry like everybody kind of knew
each other and everybody
talked about each other and everything
so it it actually I think it helped me
get get my name out even more because I
was I did have a knack for writing it
seemed and I did eventually start
posting some pretty good stuff and um
and so that kind of got talked about and
shared do you remember what was uh like
kind of your first thing that broke out
and really in that era I really don't I
really don't it was so
gradual man like my
it's funny because you know subtle art
is so massive like
I it was funny this is jumping ahead a
little bit but like when subtle art came
out and it blew up and it was like at
the top all the best seller lists and
stuff like everybody in the publishing
industry were like oh you're like the
new Phenom debuted author overnight
success I was I'm like overnight success
I've been [__] grinding on a Blog for
10 years like what do you mean overnight
success right yeah I was doing like you
know that's like the low status thing in
society like yeah I'm a blogger yes
exactly so you're unemployed like what
is that dude
I got stories
I got story I remember uh
like 2013 2014 and by this time my like
my audience was pretty big like I had a
few hundred thousand readers and uh I
remember going home for Christmas one
year and uh kind of got in an argument
with my parents and my my stepmom was
just like when are you gonna get a real
job and and and she was like you know I
know such and such like they're hiring
like a web designer you know you could
go do that and I was like that'd be a
waste of my time and she's like oh you
could probably make a hundred thousand a
year I was like I already make a hundred
thousand a year and she just looked at
me and she goes no you don't
it's like
I was like do you want tax returns like
Jesus Christ what do I have to do to get
you people to believe in me but uh
anyway we're jumping around now um
you know the con yeah the content side I
don't know I just I had this weird
confidence of like
I saw that Bill Simmons trajectory over
the page two days and I'm and he did it
differently than everybody else and I
was like why can't I do that right and I
I'm not gonna post 20 times a day I'm
just gonna do like one Epic article that
everybody gets excited about and that
was kind of my Mo and it's funny because
that eventually became the meta kind of
the more Facebook era
um in the early 2010s uh so I was like
ahead of the curve I guess
on the marketing side I was trash I was
just like selling does not come natural
to me at all it was very much something
that I had to consciously train myself
practice
I took a bunch of copywriting courses
um
I like went to marketing seminars
pirated marketing seminars uh like that
was always it's funny because it's like
the
the psychology side the personal
development side of everything the
social dynamics the relationship advice
like
that all came very easily and naturally
to me yeah and it was just it was fun it
was like kind of a hobby so it was like
I never really had to like work hard to
kind of figure that out like anything I
was working on getting better at in my
business it was always the sales and
marketing stuff right like figuring that
[__] out
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
[Music]
so you've done uh so those content reps
got in you obviously became a great
writer and we'll talk about the book in
a second but I want to talk about what
you're doing now which is the YouTube
video sure or the YouTube channel and
yeah it seems like that's I don't know
is that you're like it's not like the
main thing is that like this is not my
baby right now that's the new main thing
yeah and so uh I think you dropped the
first first like
um video maybe a couple days ago and
doing Super Bowl can you pull it up I
want to actually do a little so one of
my favorite little content things is
this um this thing that happens in
sports and football uh they like take
quarterbacks that are about to be
drafted and I don't know if you've ever
seen they see they sit down they like
look at game film with them just to see
kind of how they think sure and um it's
my favorite thing in any podcast is like
when you can really like not like
talking the abstract yeah talking the
specific like like why did you do this
yeah I think about this yeah um and we
hung out with Mr Beast and we did that
with some of his videos and the way he
thinks he's like oh okay I get it I get
like I learned something tactical but
also just I get you more yeah
um versus when you ask some general
questions and so I kind of want to play
this game I don't know how to work but
we'll try I want to know the thought
that went into this let's watch the
first 10 seconds I wanna hear you talk
about it okay what would you do if
someone offered you ten thousand dollars
to do whatever it takes to overcome your
social anxiety could you do it would you
even know where to start
I decided to find out all right let's
pause right there yeah yeah all right
walk me through that well a lot was
happening there what was how you think
about this obviously some Mr Beast
inspiration here he was very
inspirational so let me zoom out for a
second uh uh more broadly and then I can
kind of come back to this video
specifically so early in my career I did
a lot of coaching first with the pickup
stuff and then just kind of like life
advice in general I stopped coaching
for a lot of reasons but one of them is
I was consistent I was very frustrated
by it which was that I feel like the
incent like the way the incentives are
structured within coaching Industries uh
in the personal development world are
counterproductive right so it's like if
you're paying me a bunch like let's say
I don't know you have like self-esteem
issues and you're paying me a bunch of
money to like help you out
it's first of all my incentive isn't to
fix your self-esteem issues like my my
incentive is to make it feel like I'm
fixing your self-esteem issues even
though they're still there like a
pharmaceutical company right exactly
assure you
exactly and then on your side of the
equation uh it's what often happens in
practice like or on the customer side is
what often happens in practice is people
kind of show up they pay you say a
thousand dollars and they're like well I
just paid you a thousand dollars so you
deal with it right like I've been
dealing with this my whole life I just
paid you a bunch of money you deal with
it now right like that's actually what
they're looking for
and so I hated that Dynamic it felt very
I mean it works some of the time but in
a lot of cases it felt very icky and
I've kind of found myself in like
awkward situations with clients and
stuff uh so I just got away from it uh
entirely and just kind of stuck the
books and courses and everything
when I saw Mr Beast
a light bulb went off I was like
because I love Mr Beast and like I've
been watching his [__] for a long time
but one of my frustrations with him is
that it's all very
surface level like I'll watch a Mr B's
video and I'll get to the end and I'm
like I want to know about the guys
character yeah I'm like tell me about
the guy we won or tell me like you're
down to four people tell me about their
lives like bring their families in like
I want to see let's get some juicy drama
going right I talked to him about this
yeah and I was like uh because I was
like he was talking about like a Netflix
or like TV shows yeah and it was like oh
like yeah what can you learn about TV
show what do you learn from like TV
shows that have been running for a long
time do really well um
and he he says he's like uh also I think
they can learn a lot from us and he's
like yeah he's like I'd love to see
their retention curve
um right they just don't know where
people are dropping off he's like what
we found was like if you hit him hit him
hit him with like the more of like the
action and the stakes and then the the
quest and like the Curiosity you open
the loop and like that's gonna keep
people he's like but he's like but I do
think the one thing TV does well is
characteristic we don't do any narrative
or character and I gotta figure out how
I'm gonna do that yeah he's like I don't
know how to do that yet but like we
should probably learn that yeah so this
is this is kind of another side
statement and this gets more into like
my personal strategy or like
opportunities I see in the future but
like
it's the current media environment I
think traditional media
they've always had the luxury of having
that lock-in of like you're in a theater
and it's more it's like once you're in a
theater it's more difficult to leave
than to sit through a bad movie so
everybody just sits through a bad movie
you know it and it's and the previous
era of Television it's you know you
don't want to sit there and like flip
around for 10 minutes looking for
something else so you sit there and just
kind of watch a mediocre show so it's
like traditional media is coming from a
hundred years of a luxury of just having
that buy-in and having you like locked
in and and so they can take the time it
requires to build character build
narrative build build build drama right
and and create those very emotional
moments that we've all had with our
favorite movies and TV shows
YouTube is kind of the other way around
like there's always [__] fighting for
your attention and trying to get you to
click off and so YouTube is just
retention retention retention like it's
merciless and absolutely brutal and so I
think we're in an interesting media
environment where
YouTubers have become masters of
retention and the content on YouTube is
super hooky and click the rig right like
those two two variables yes and super
hooky very clickbaity like addictive but
also kind of empty calories like you can
just blow through like six videos and
just be like wait what I don't remember
a single thing I just watched
and that's kind of unsatisfying
traditional media is like caught in the
other side of things of like wait [__]
like people are watching our shows now
with like their phones in front of them
and they're like they've now got five
different streaming services they can
pick from and they can switch easily
switch to another movie like mid-movie
right and so they're trying to catch up
on the retention side of things and I
think YouTube is trying to catch up on
the the character development and drama
side of things and I think whoever
figures it out first is gonna like win
really big but anyway back to the Mr
Beast thing and the coaching thing so I
was watching Mr Beast videos
for a couple years and then like last
year I was I was kind of taking this
break and I was trying to figure out
what I was going to do next in my own
career
and I had felt this about his videos for
a long time and and I started thinking
I'm like man like what if you
what if you built the challenges in a
way that like forced character
development like what are the challenges
weren't built around like you know stand
in a circle or uh you know keep your
hand on a car like what if it was built
around on this Lamborghini yeah like
what if it was built around like a real
personal issue that like you have to
investigate to like try to understand
right and and that's when the light bulb
went off because I'm like not only does
that
potentially create like very amazing
transformative YouTube content but it
solves that coaching issue as well
because when you take somebody who's
struggled their entire life with say
anxiety or an issue the problem is never
that this comes back to the information
thing the problem is never I don't have
the information to fix my problem the
problem is they're just not doing it
right like they're not [__] going out
and doing it and so
and they could pay a coach a thousand
bucks and the coach can say okay well
you paid me a thousand bucks now go do
it and sometimes that works but not
always or you could say I'll give you a
thousand bucks if you go to it and fix
your own [__] right like what does that
look like right like what is like the
most effective lever for Behavior change
is financial incentive and so what if
you actually create Financial incentive
for people to actually go deal with
their [__] and like do the things that
they've always known that they need to
do and they've just never had the guts
to do it and so that's when I was like
holy that's kind of Genius yeah I was
like [__] I need to make this uh so this
is our first attempt at it and it's
funny because this was shot end of April
early may this is we're recording this
end of July
um
there are like I'm already aware of like
15 things that are wrong with this video
and like they're like it's it's actually
underperforming our expectations and
like there's so many things that we need
to fix but it's your first rep yeah it's
the first rep it's like the first it's
like the beta test but super super
excited about the format that makes a
ton of sense and uh also like even just
mechanically like the things you just
said so if you know coaching is getting
somebody to like transform uh the way
the Transformers not information just
doing it yeah best way to get somebody
to do is if maybe a financial incentive
or even like the fact that they agree to
be in the content there's a contract
there to like do the thing
um
but you also how can you offer ten
thousand dollars to why could you pay
your clothes that's not a sustainable
business but it is if it's YouTube
content you have like almost the full
loop to be able to make something it
creates it creates a very beautiful
flywheel of
you're helping that individual so in
this video it's a woman named Melinda so
I'm helping Melinda and she did get
amazing results uh you know she's
finally doing the things that she's
always known that she should do or has
always wanted to do you get to all the
people watching because I could easily
make a video of me sitting at a desk
talking about social anxiety for 15
minutes everybody's heard the same [__]
they've all like everybody knows what
I'm gonna say now millions of people get
to actually watch somebody overcome
their character overcomes yeah it's like
oh that's what it looks like oh that's
what
how people respond in that situation you
know the difference between watching
Rocky and then some or somebody sitting
in a chair and saying you just gotta
work really hard yeah yeah it's a
different emotional register and a lot
of people remember 20 years later and
still think about when you work out yeah
and the other one you don't totally so
it's the
qualitative feedback on this
it's been honestly it's been some of the
best of my entire like we if you look
through the comments of this video
there's tons of comments of people
saying I cried right this was me oh my
God like I was not expecting this this
is so powerful you know it it's pretty
incredible and so how did you think
about those first 10 15 seconds I don't
know how long we went but like what are
you trying to achieve in those first 15
seconds of this video
so that with YouTube content there's
always this question of like what's the
hook like what's going to get people to
buy in what's going to get people to
stick around
and one of the challenges that we face
with this format is that all of the
all the stuff that we're having people
do
it's it's super abstract like social
social anxiety is super abstract like
how do you show social anxiety it's like
not very obvious how you show that
visually uh or like low self-esteem how
do you show that visually so
we were thinking about like okay what
are like kind of like hooks or gimmicks
that we can like Implement into the
format that can get people bought in
right and the first and most obvious in
this in the current Mr Beast briefcase
is [__] money right it's like
everybody on YouTube's doing it it seems
to be working for a lot of people so
kind of the obvious starting point is
like okay well what are we Jedi right
Jedi in the nums yes what if you gave
him ten thousand dollars
but the funny thing is is that it
actually this intro did not perform very
well yeah and so what is that what tells
you that like you're looking at the
curve you're like the retention chart
what should it have been yeah for what
do you think it should have been to be
like good well I think though the issue
with this is that even though it's money
it's still it's still not visual enough
it's still too abstract and so I think
what we've learned from this one is that
the new approach needs to be we just
need to start like mid challenge so like
the first challenge in this video is
just approach we yeah we take her into a
mall and we tell her she has to find
somebody from Canada and like she by the
way it's so funny because she it's it's
so like relatable this is why I think
you should have started with this I was
actually gonna suggest this yeah it's so
related because you tell her like
someone in this mall is from Canada you
need to go approach them and ask them
and find them and she's like nervous
laugh and then she starts like faking
being on a phone yeah like which is
everybody's done it like and then she's
like it's like are you faking a phone
it's like yeah I am I just I don't know
it makes me feel more comfortable dude
she was so relatable such a spaz right
such a spaz it was really fun and and
yeah in hindsight it's like we should
have just opened up with that and then
explain the format later yeah uh but
like
yeah I mean we're new we're we're
Paving the road as we drive so cast yes
which is hard and you don't know what's
gonna happen and like this is kind of
reality TV for sure and there's also
like how this I would say this is a
common theme from the pickup to uh
subtle art to now this which is how do
you avoid selling out so like yeah when
you've been in the the industry you kind
of know okay if I pull this lever I'm
gonna get more juice yep
like maybe maybe this will let's just
pretend If This Woman's transformation
was not that that crazy but like in the
edit you could kind of like oh for sure
make this video better it's like do we
want to have our video be better or
worse obviously better but at the same
time we don't want to sell out how have
you just dealt with that like how hard
do I want to turn the knob or pull the
lever of like
you know manipulation to make something
work the few that we've shot all of them
have been very successful so far but
I've told the team that I want to be
eventually we're going to hit one that's
not successful like we don't help the
person it doesn't work right or maybe we
help them a little but
they don't get there right uh
I think it's very very important to be
honest about that and to actually make a
video like have the video kind of
explore why that is right you know
um because it's
yeah there's a credibility and
authenticity that it's just so so
important especially and that's
it's been one of my criticisms of my own
industry for 10 15 years of just like
the lack of trustworthiness the lack of
credibility because if you promise the
magic pill that works in two minutes
you're gonna sell more and if you say
this takes you two years of tough work
right right so you've probably dealt
with that a bunch and like maybe now you
know you got [__] you money from the
book and you're like no I don't have to
do that anymore you know I guess how's
that changed well I'm very fortunate in
that the book did well first of all it
is true the book did so well that I do
have [__] you money so I don't really
care like this is this YouTube Project's
losing money and it's probably gonna
lose money for a year or two and all
right fine with that uh but like it's
I'm also very fortunate that I made my
money being very explicit about that
that like there is no magic pill there
is no cure-all like it's funny dude like
even when you dig into research on uh
therapies like what modality of therapy
is the most effective right
you start looking at the research and
it's
it's startling because there's nothing
that has more than a 50 hit rate nothing
like not there's no form of therapy that
is successful like produces positive
outcomes more than 50 percent of the
time which is crazy because it's like
therapy is like the most tried and true
like we've had it for 200 years like
it's the one thing everybody's like is
directed to go to so there's in the
world of psychology there's just so much
that we don't know what works like in
what works for you could completely fail
for me and vice versa because
everybody's so individual so to your
point about casting
a huge part of our casting process is
doing
pre-shoot interviews me doing pre-shoot
conversations and interviews with the
person to really gauge of like is this a
person I can help because for every
video we shot we talked to probably two
or three people and half of those people
I'm like you know not really confident I
can actually like right get them over
the line whereas like with this with
this woman you know I talk to her in
within 10 minutes I'm like yeah right
now I could give me a week with her I'm
like I could get I can get something out
of it you know did you um do you watch
the TV show The Bear by any chance I
have not everybody says It's amazing but
I'm not yet yeah it's actually it's a
little bit I would say it's a little bit
slow but it pays off it's the thing you
talked about which is like the retention
curve for me was terrible at the
beginning because it's slow it's like
it's like one of those like cool shows
where it's like you know we're not gonna
like be clickbaity yeah and I'm like I'm
kind of used to that hit so you know
like if you're really gonna pay this off
with character it's gonna take some time
but man it does there's like a episode
in the second season it's like such a
huge payoff on character that like
now I'm like telling everybody you gotta
watch the show just get into the second
season get to the end of it yeah you
know it's so so satisfying but they're
um but we so we reached out to one of
the writers and we were like hey there's
respect and uh just we like to learn
from people like that like how do you do
this how do you do this character thing
um have you learned anything in the
process of like doing these videos of
like
because it's new it's not writing it's
not books you now have like casting and
characters and stuff you probably
haven't done before like first of all
I'm learning a million things one of the
reasons I wanted to do this too I should
specify is like
you know I came out of this period the
post subtle art period of my career
I did three books back to back to back I
did a movie like a bunch of traditional
media success like everything was
wildly successful very busy lots of
money
I moved to LA I took it took a few
months off and I was just like man I
miss like the grindy Grassroots internet
right stuff right and but what I also
realized is like I miss being bad at
something like I miss
I miss just like throwing [__] at a wall
and being like did that work like no all
right let's try this you know like and
and in traditional media I don't you
don't really have the flexibility to do
that like you're you're being
if a studio or a large publisher is
bringing you in it's because like they
know you can make a hit and you need to
make a [__] hit and
so I I miss the internet days of like
all right let's try 10 things and just
know that like six are gonna fail and uh
like that's just exciting to me and so
part of this project was like
I want to learn I want to get back on a
learning curve and like experience that
again and so yeah I've been learning a
million things about video production
about
um storytelling visual storytelling in
particular like one of the big lessons
from this video is that I still very
much just write like a book writer like
a lot of the mistakes that were made in
this video
it's because it was organized in such a
way that would work really well on like
an article or a book right but it works
terribly on video what's an example so
an example is for is like the intro
right it's like that's a great intro on
paper
it's a terrible intro on video because
it's abstract it's not visually
interesting you know it's like you start
with the challenge right this woman spaz
running around a mall like ask people if
they're from Canada like that's super
weird and you're like what what's going
on and then it's like you slowly like
drip context over the course of like 10
minutes whereas when you're writing
a book or or an article like you have
you need to put all the context up front
of like this is what we're doing this is
what this is about you know it's like
the old school essay it's like you gotta
have your thesis in the first paragraph
and then you got to have your three
bullets and like all this stuff so I
still my brain still kind of defaults to
that and I'm having like untrained
myself in a lot of ways
the funny thing is is like and again one
of the reasons I'm doing this is
I think my natural strength is story and
character and narrative like that
that's where I shine naturally what I'm
weaker at is the retention the hooks the
like
uh gen Z [__] the Gen Z [__] yeah yeah
actually yeah exactly there's something
I've ever heard this term like the
millennial pause no it's so funny it's
like if you were to it's like what's up
on your pause it's basically gen Z
people if you watch the start of their
video starts with them already they're
already talking so they're like mid word
oh yeah as the video starts whereas
every Millennial is like they click
record like
hey everybody it's like that little like
that little pause it's like you're
already swiped on Tick Tock if you
haven't like you got to be like mid
interesting thing and I was like that's
so [__] true that's funny that's so
true
so you're doing this this uh series
what's like the craziest or most
interesting challenge I guess you can't
give it away too much but like what what
concepts are like oh I can't wait to see
how that's gonna turn out or like I
really want to try something like this a
lot of the the social stuff is like the
most interesting because it's you can do
a lot of fear-based stuff I mean you can
take somebody up in a plane and throw
them out you know make them Skydive or
whatever and that's exciting but like I
don't know it it doesn't feel like
there's as much depth as like the social
stuff so uh we have a challenge in
another video where I printed out Flat
Earth Flyers saying like you know do you
do you know the truth about the planet
you know it's a picture of a flat Earth
and I made her go into a public place
and hand them out to people right and
like try to convince them to be flat
earthers and choose it's like absolutely
mortified like just horrified and uh but
it's super fun because then it's like
well why do you care like you don't know
these people you're never gonna see them
again like why do you care why is it so
horrifying right like it's just yeah
it's super exciting for me this is
honestly it's the most fun I'm having in
my career and probably
six or seven years
which is a dope lesson because you know
you wrote a book with Will Smith yeah a
movie or you know you got to do a bunch
of things that like I would say are like
the on paper like the hashtag goals
people think they want and uh like
actually that's not where the source of
joy and happiness comes from yeah I
think you I think you had said something
which was like happiness is from solving
problems yep is that is that you yeah
which is when you start at the beginning
of a learning curve you're just gonna
suck and solve a bunch of problems to
make something good yeah and that's a
lot more satisfying than uh for me at
least it is you know I'm sure there are
people out there who prefer like kind of
a traditional media environment but one
of the things I learned is that
I can do traditional media projects and
I can do very well at them but like
I don't feel that same passion with them
as I do with stuff like this like I like
owning my own stuff I like
experimenting I like the creative
process like having the complete
creative freedom and then also owning it
and then also getting the package it and
also like controlling the brand around
it like it's
also part of I mean we can talk about
this too but um
it's it's funny like so when my movie
came out and I did all the press for the
movie
every single journalist I talked to was
like so are you gonna do another movie
and like in my head I'm like [__] no
absolutely not I'm gonna go make a
YouTube channel because it's like that
was actually my lesson from making a
movie was like I should ask I should
just have a YouTube channel like this
because
the economics of the Creator economy are
fundamentally better the distribution is
Miles better
you've like complete ownership there's
complete creative freedom like I I just
don't see how
this doesn't end up ahead right in 10
years
it's like hanging by like a Prestige
thread it really is right I'm like oh
yeah Status it really is and it's I'm
sure I I don't think like Hollywood's
gonna die but I I imagine it's going to
be very similar to like kind of what's
happened with like newspapers and
Twitter of like
there's still prestigious newspapers and
they still kind of matter a little bit
like it's still nice to like be in the
New York Times or whatever but
the real intellectual debate and
substance and like the stuff that drives
culture happens on Twitter and sub stack
and has for years now right and it's
like I think we're coming up on an
inflection point that that's that's also
going to happen in video and audio based
media I think it's probably already
happened with podcasts and it's about to
happen with video as well where it's
like yeah there's still going to be like
Marvel movies and stuff and Netflix is
gonna have its TV shows and it's gonna
be very prestigious to be on those but
like culture is going to be driven by
like it probably within this decade
creators they're gonna grow up for one
uh and two the production value is going
to get better the storytelling is going
to get better and it's gonna it's gonna
hit an inflection point where it starts
driving culture and not
the traditional media if it's not
already I mean
I think if you're under 25 it is already
right fair enough I want to talk to you
about titles because I think you're a
title master
um do you think you're good at titles
apparently I am I guess
I don't feel good at them but the book
obviously has a good title and it
started with the book came from a blog
post correctly it wasn't intended to be
like a book it was like yeah here's a
blog post why'd you know to turn that
one into a book by the way does it like
did it hit in a different way or yeah
that that is that one I mean I had a lot
of Articles go viral over that period
like 2012 to 2015 like I probably had 10
or 12 articles go super viral but that
one just hit on like a whole another
level like it was so I had already
written probably half the book when that
article came out and then when that
article hit the way it did my agent was
like hey uh I think you could uh change
the title of the book yeah and you
hadn't done a book and years right
before that no I just done models right
so you're uh you're you're but you're
already thinking about a book and then
it was like yep oh lean into this one
yeah so there's this a little picture or
diagram that's is that did you make that
or um the one with the guy floating away
on the balloons oh that was is that a
from something what is this that was an
old meme back in the day okay so good
yeah yeah I love it and that's that's
like as good as that midwit Meme it's
like yes this image can become like yeah
you know transformational it's funny
yeah I haven't seen that that I used
that used to be around everywhere back
in like 2013 2014 and then it's I
haven't seen it in a long time right
there was also the original article also
because back then a big part of
packaging an article for like Facebook
and Twitter was what image pops up yeah
that when you share and so we we used to
spend a lot of you know kind of similar
like thumbnails on YouTube we used to
spend a lot of time like looking for the
right image for the share share image on
on Facebook and uh
I think the other thing that made that
article work was
I think on Reddit one day just randomly
on Reddit I saw somebody had
photoshopped a picture of a kitten in
front of like a bomb exploding yeah
it's huge yeah and so we pulled that and
used that as like the share yeah the
share the share image and it was just
kind of this magical combo of content
title
image and it just like all works do you
remember how you thought of that title
so the subtle art of not giving a [__]
where does that come from oh you're
sitting down are you just hammering out
a bunch of possibilities or I back then
I used to keep a list of article ideas
like just kind of a running list of
ideas that I would just add to like I'd
have conversations with people and
something would pop up and I just pull
out my phone added to the list
um and it came from it came from there
was a heavy metal song uh
from a band called Lamb of God data data
song called the subtle art of murder and
persuasion and um
and at that time I had just done
I think two different articles with
[__] the time like I I had just kind
of discovered that if you put [__]
the title it would go further it would
yeah everything would go further so I
was like adding [__] to all my titles or
to a bunch of my my titles at the time
and so I was just kind of on the lookout
of like cool titles that you could add
add [__] into
um and I think I knew I wanted to do an
article about not giving a [__] uh
because I was just an obvious topic uh
and so when I heard that song I was like
well subtle are not even like that's
pretty damn good like I should use that
let's pull up some of your other ones so
you have uh the most important question
of your life yep that's good that was a
huge one because you gotta know I need
to know yeah what is this jackass think
you know it's like probably nothing but
let me just check yeah the most
important x uh like it's it's always
gonna work you have uh life is a video
game and here are the cheat codes yeah
it's like a you know Master path that
that's become uh I feel like that's
become a it's so this is the other thing
like I think a lot of I guess my skill
with this just came from cranking out
articles in the Facebook era of like
trying to get articles to go viral
because it was like so much of it had to
do with the title and
it's been interesting you know now it's
been 10 years it's been interesting
because some of these have kind of just
become I guess classic yeah yeah like
it's you just see there's probably 10
different brands that use these same
titles all the time and like the life is
a video game one is like I see that
everywhere I wrote This Thread about
um that the first line of it was
everybody everybody seems to think
Clubhouse is the next big thing yeah
um but I think it's gonna fail
and it's like uh grab some popcorn
here's here's how I think it goes down
yeah yeah and
um that thing went crazy viral and like
uh I like my hero Malcolm gladwells are
following me Bill Simmons DMS me it's
like oh [__] this is like this is
amazing I didn't know this could happen
because like today the Facebook meta
doesn't really work but like Twitter
threads actually for a period of time
last recently could could go viral and
uh and now that same theme is like
people just like AI is the next big
thing but here's a you know he grab some
popcorn here's how I think it goes down
it's like a good copy paste but it
obviously like loses effect of course as
it goes that's the other interesting
thing too that's kind of changed in the
last 10 years like there was real
and I I don't have any moral judgment
around this but it's you know 10 years
ago it was very much a sense of like if
you came up with a title that like like
a banger it was like that was yours
right yeah you know it's like No And if
somebody stole it it was like they're a
piece of [__] and then you call them out
and your audience would call them out
and like I used to get emails from fans
being like this guy copied your article
I'm like all this stuff like I never get
those emails anymore like it's everybody
just rips everybody off now and so
anybody who posts anything that goes
viral anywhere there's like the next day
there's Half-Life there's 20 more
versions on every platform and it's just
like it's the way the game's played
today it's that Meme that it's like you
know I made this thing and then it's
like they're like
I made this I made this yeah yeah I
don't think people even are aware of it
anymore yeah
um is blogging dead
I think it it depends on how you define
dead so
there was an ERA in the early 2010s
where
a you a Blog could gain reach Beyond its
own specific Niche like it you could
kind of get mainstream audience like hit
hit like a critical mass I think today
you can still make a living off a Blog
it's just you've got to have your Niche
figured out you gotta like really be
tuned into them and you're probably
never going to scale an audience past
like
low six figures
um whereas ten years ago I mean I think
at my Peak I was getting like two two
and a half million visitors a month
that's right so it's it's a it's a
different world now it is still possible
but it's like I think it really only
If You're Gonna Go blog route instead of
podcaster video like it it you have to
have a really good reason and it
probably has to be a very specific Niche
to do it did you podcast or do you
podcast I do not is there like a reason
or Why didn't I never started one just
because of lack of bandwidth uh just
like writing too many books
um
and then but now that I'm doing the
video stuff like I'm probably gonna do
something in the podcasting space it
won't be something like this like last
thing the world needs is another
interview podcast don't step on my turf
yeah yeah right I made this I made this
this is mine yeah but
um I do think it's I think it I would
like to be in this medium in some shape
or form so right uh you did a book with
Will Smith and presumably spent a bunch
of time with Will Smith yep you know
when people meet celebrities I always
ask like what do they like yeah it's not
like
I know it's just a real specific
question it's kind of like that's what
everyone how are they yeah everybody is
like how are they as a person yeah it's
kind of like you know like are they big
are they awesome there's like that
version of it but to me I'm sort of like
what was this what was something you saw
them do or like something you witnessed
that was like just not how the common
person would have approached a given
situation
so the quick answer to the the one
everybody always asks which is like
what's he like in person he is
exactly like the Fresh Prince like that
is I spent the I remember spending one
day with him and then I went back to the
hotel and and called my wife and I was
like he did not act on that show like I
said they literally just put him in a
room and then put actors around the
front like that is that is his
personality will will is like there are
a few Dimensions that I think he is like
at the extreme end of the bell curve the
the most obvious one that's not going to
surprise anybody is just this Charisma
like he
is by far the most naturally charismatic
bird I mean it can literally just be
like me and him
sitting in a kitchen
at midnight
talking about cartoon like he's so
charismatic just like
built into him and so it's not hard you
spend a little bit of time with him and
it's not hard to see and understand like
oh okay I see why this guy's so famous
his mind is is very
almost delusionally positive like he
kind of has this like you know we all
have a little bit of a the psychologist
Dan Gilbert calls it a psychological
immune system which is like when bad
things happen we kind of like
rationalize or explain them in a way
that you know makes us feel better or
helps us his psychological immune system
like it's just
negativity just bounces right off him
any sort of failure setback like he
doesn't doesn't bum him out like I I've
never really been around somebody who is
so easily to like able to construe
challenges and obstacles in a way that
that is confident and beneficial like
it's actually very impressive but it's
funny because it also gets him in
trouble like when there actually is a
problem that needs to be addressed and
you do need to be sad and you do need to
like deal with it
he just rationalizes it in such a
positive way so quickly that it kind of
like it can cause problems for him and
that's that's actually one thing he and
I talked about for the book is that you
know he came from a very chaotic and
like abusive childhood and
he said he's like I developed that as
like a survival mechanism
and it's helped me so much throughout my
life and my career like I'm just
absolutely Relentless like anything goes
wrong it never bothers me like I just
get up and do it again
but yeah it's like I'm a little bit
untethered to reality sometimes
uh so that that's like that was very
interesting and and remarkable when you
saw the
Chris Rock slap or whatever
that's obviously kind of like
not like you know Mr positive or
whatever in that moment were you like
yeah what was your kind of were you like
stunned uh like because you know him
more than like everybody's shocked
because it's a shocking thing yeah when
you know the person
you might have like either it's even
more shocking than that or it's less
because you understood it maybe it was
coming from it was definitely less
shocking for me
um he slapped you once or twice yeah
you're like yeah it's common
keep her name out of your mouth uh no I
mean like one of the things
and we this is in the book he had a very
abusive alcoholic father
used to beat the [__] out of his mom and
he was the oldest he was the oldest
child he was the male right so he felt
responsible and very protective and so
he has a lot of issues around women he's
very protective he's very sensitive
like
the women in his life are his Achilles
heel like that's if you want to get to
him like that's the route like you can
talk [__] about him all day all night
he's gonna sit there and laugh he fine
whatever it's like you go after his mom
his daughter or his wife like
shit's gonna get real real fast and so I
wasn't surprised it was funny actually I
was watching it with my wife live and
like my wife turned to me and she was
like this is a bit right I was like no
but that's not a bit like he's actually
saying that right now she's like what
she sent him a text afterwards or you
like just give him space because the
Uber famous people you like it's hard to
even navigate it's like you don't want
to be one of those people yeah girls
like if I'm your friend do I just send
you something like yeah it's weird
that's a whole like we could spend an
hour just talking about that that's like
super weird it's funny too because it's
like everybody who I've ever known in my
life message me that night
asking for like my opinion whatever and
I'm like literally people like I haven't
talked to since high school you know are
like reaching out I'm like wait this is
the thing that got you to reach out like
all the [__] I did you didn't like
didn't bother like you know couldn't be
bothered to say anything but like this
this got you to reach out to me all
right all right yeah that that was just
I mean it like something can win the
internet for the day and like yeah on
the internet it has like insane reach it
was insane yeah amazing thanks for doing
this by the way I know you uh you know
you kind of didn't know what you're
gonna do I hope you enjoyed it have you
had a fun time yeah I definitely did
because
you're somebody I followed for a long
time and I think the people I respect
the most like some people respect like
Elon Musk the most some people respect
because it's like oh he conquers like
you know taking us to another planet
yeah uh but I always admire thinkers
like I think uh a great thinker somebody
who's who puts out original thoughts and
I don't know makes you think about the
world a little differently those are my
favorite types of people so I really
appreciate you coming on thanks dude I'm
glad glad we did it absolutely man where
do you want people to go the YouTube
channel I'm assuming is check out the
YouTube channel there's gonna be more of
those videos coming out Mark Manson what
is that yeah if you just search Mark
Manson on Youtube it'll it'll pop up and
then uh parkmanson.net got a newsletter
there
um
and I think that's you know buy the
books whatever
I don't give a [__] yeah I don't give a
[__] buy my [__]
awesome cool that's right all right
[Music]